the World Health Organization is facing
growing criticism not just from the US
president has the w-h-o been handling
the pandemic as well as it could or have
there been shortcomings before we
address these questions let's have a
look at what the w-h-o is and what is
within its remedy health for all that is
the primary goal of the World Health
Organization 7,000 employees work for
this specialized agency of the United
Nations the w-h-o provides guidelines on
healthy living for example on the
prevention of diabetes or the dangers of
smoking the organization also sets
standards such as in quality control for
food or medicine or with regards to
water or air pollution it promotes the
development of health systems in
developing countries and the production
of vaccines in the event of a crisis
such as kovat 19 its role does not
extend beyond assessing the global
situation and giving recommendations the
w-h-o has an annual budget of around 2
billion dollars to compare the United
Nations Children's Fund spent three
times that amount in 2018 welcome to
this edition of kovat 19 special here on
DW news I'm Chris Coburn in Berlin it's
good to have you with us now the number
of global coronavirus infections has
surged past the mark of two million and
fighting a pandemic in real time makes
it an accounting of potential missteps
difficult but as the outbreak progresses
there are people calling upon the World
Health Organization to explain past
actions in dealing with the corona virus
on December 31 2019 Chinese authorities
told the World Health Organization about
a mysterious flu-like illness spreading
in the city of Wuhan two weeks later the
whu-oh published a tweet it would soon
be haunted by preliminary investigations
conducted by the Chinese authorities
have found no clear evidence of
human-to-human transmission of the novel
coronavirus
identified in Wuhan China
the next day a man flew from Wuhan to
the US becoming the country's first case
it would take another two weeks before
the statement from the whu-oh I'm
declaring a public health emergency of
international concern over the global
outbreak of novel : of a corona virus
cases around the world snowballed at an
alarming rate blowing past 2 million as
of today US President Donald Trump under
heavy criticism for his handling of the
crisis sought to level blame at the
whu-oh he accused it of failing to hold
China responsible and of withholding
early vital information our countries
are now experiencing you look all over
the world
tremendous death and economic
devastation because those tasked with
protecting us by being truthful and
transparent failed to do so
dealing with a pandemic in the present
makes looking back at past steps
difficult but as the death toll mounts
so do the calls for accountability who
should have behaved differently and when
the whu-oh may over the world some
answers now we would have liked to talk
to a w-h-o representative about this
issue but he cancelled the interview on
short notice so we're grateful to be
joined by an AHA fighter a senior
researcher on governance for global
health at the Berlin Social Science
Center welcome to the program Anna we
just saw in the report it took the wh0
one month after it first learned about
the virus in China to declare an
international public health emergency
and it declared the outbreak a pandemic
on March 11th was the organization too
slow to act well I guess we are seeing
accusations of an appropriate slow or
risky responses to the covered 19
pandemic everywhere not last with
regards to how the US and the UK have
been initially dealing with the outbreak
so why would we assume that an
organization that's made up of a hundred
and ninety-four member states that has
virtually no sanctioning power of
various
more budget and a huge mandate is free
of the power politics that surround us M
pandemic and the power politics that we
can witness nationally and
internationally so the W Jo is like all
other international organizations
depending on reliable information from
its member states on contagious
outbreaks of contagious diseases and
it's also heavily marked of course by
so-called health diplomacy that is
attempts by its most influential member
states and that includes the United
States and China to push through their
specific interests not only in times of
crisis but always so does that mean that
the w-h-o did not get the proper data
from the Chinese well it's always a very
sensitive issue particular when we're
talking about infectious diseases that
have a potential to develop into a
pandemic we've already seen that during
the the Sarris outbreaks in 2002-2003
and it is it happens very rarely that
international organizations that depend
on the Member States for financing for
support openly criticized particularly
individual member states for their
behavior so it's a very what we are
seeing is a kind of a typical behavior
of an international organization and I
think it's also a rather bizarre and
naive picture of international
organizations that we assume they're
somewhat beyond politics hmm so the
criticism that not only the US President
Donald Trump has voiced regarding this
behavior of the of the w-h-o but has
been echoed by other governments around
the world they're so married to it
well you're pushing me to make a
specific argument I would say yes the
international organizations that are
there at large and that have that little
autonomous power are very prone to
reacting slowly we've also seen that
governments have reacted slowly even
though they may have more they obviously
have much more decision-making power so
it is undeniable that what we are seeing
here in the context of the WTO but also
in the wider United Nations system is a
struggle between the United Nations in
the United States and China okay over
like the authority in these
organizations and that includes of
course also that we are seeing that
Chinese trying to take advantage of the
WTO in that situation yes okay Anna
let's talk money let's start financing
the US says it's freezing
it's a share of the whu-oh funding a
hundred and sixteen million dollars
annually
how big a blow is this well I mean it's
it seems extraordinary because we are
it's now all over the news
that is also quite typical behavior for
the United States and in order to put
pressure on international organizations
and it's also so so now it's like this
big threat of freezing the funds it has
done this before in the 1970s for
example when the wgo moved to this
health for all agenda that you just
mentioned in the teaser and was accused
of being a communist organization but
all countries in the world have very
much reduced their regular budgets to
the WTO which means that it has really
lost an autonomy over the past two
decades roughly and is that a problem
the losing of autonomy financial
autonomy well it is a problem it's a
problem because it gives the
organization very little leeway and
setting its own priorities it makes it
so susceptible to powerful states that
then push in and and try to capture the
organization and it's also it leaves a
void that's very often then filled by
for example private philanthropies like
the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
and that are then beyond any kind of
parliamentary or democratic control so
this is this is not typical to the WTO
we are seeing this everywhere in
multilateral organizations at the moment
an AHA strata of the Berlin Social
Science Center thank you for speaking to
DW next up are your questions the one of
the corona virus pandemic that you've
been sending us and the man to answer
them is our science editor Derek
Williams is math testing fork Ovid 19 a
better approach than only testing for
severe cases it's grown increasingly
clear as this pandemic progresses that
the countries that took fast action have
had the most success at keeping death
rates down and a key measure they
implemented early on was testing as
quickly and as widespread as possible
because we still have no treatments
testing only severe cases at this point
mostly only provides us with statistics
like how many people kovat 19 has killed
from among the total number of people
who have tested positive for it
widespread or mass testing on the other
hand has the potential to be a powerful
tool for for prevention if you're able
to detect cases through testing before
people even begin showing symptoms you
can limit their contact with others and
really cut the number of other people
they give it to so mass testing is a
goal that many countries are now setting
but of course it's also quite a tall
order in terms of the resources that
it'll swallow is it true that three
variants of the virus exists and if so
how are they different viruses evolve as
they spread through populations often
quite quickly that's what for example
has kept us from developing an effective
vaccine for HIV it would actually be
strange if Sarris co2 wasn't changing
and and there's evidence that it already
has a recent study led by researchers at
Cambridge University identified three
different variants of the disease in 160
patients with one type most common in
Asia and the other two mostly found in
Europe and the US the three types vary
in terms of their genetic signatures
armed with information like that an
important next step will be
determine whether those and possibly
other variants affect different
populations in different ways and the
data might even help us predict future
global hot spots are there any
restrictions on sex while condoms
prevent kovat 19 transmission with the
significant percentage of the world's
population stuck in forced intimacy at
the moment it's no surprise that this is
a frequent question now leaving the
emotional and psychological aspects of
lockdown aside let's look at the science
first condoms won't prevent the
transmission of kovat 19 the evidence so
far indicates the disease is not
transmitted sexually
it's a respiratory condition that's
passed along via droplets from the mouth
and the nose so if one of the partners
is contagious kissing is probably a more
likely means of infection than
intercourse would be but according to
the doctors I've read if you live in a
single household with your partner and
minimal exposure to other possible
sources of infection there are no
reasons to restrict your sexual activity
assuming of course that neither of you
is having any kovat 19 symptoms in fact
many experts encourage intimacy in those
circumstances as a way to relieve
anxiety and lower stress